ALBERT MEYER: In
the last lecture,
we spent time talking about
the mean, or expectation,
and its properties, most
important one being linearity.
But let's step back
now and think about,
what is it that the mean means?
Why we care about it?
We have this intuitive idea that
if you do things long enough,
if you keep experimenting
with the same random variable
collecting its values,
its long run average will
be about the same as its mean.
Now, we're going to try
to make that more precise.
So we're going to talk
about the topic of deviation
from the mean, or
as I like to say,
what does the mean really mean?
Why do we care about it?
Well, let's look at
an example that's
familiar to get a grip
on the specific ideas
that we're interested in.
So suppose I toss a
fair coin 101 times.
Then, I know that the expected
number, since all the values
from zero through 101 are
possible, and the middle value
is the expectation,
it's 50 and 1/2 heads.
Now, I'm never going to get
exactly 50 and 1/2 heads.
The probability in 101 flips
of getting 50 and 1/2 heads
is zero because there's
no way to flip 1/2 a head.
So you don't expect the
expectation in that sense.
No given measurement,
no given experiment
is going to yield
the expectation.
The expectation is this
thing that we expect
to come out on the average.
Well, we can ask,
what's the probability
of getting as close as you could
hope to get to the expectation?
Namely, what's the probability
of getting exactly 50 heads?
And it's about 1/13.
Or if you ask, what's
the probability
of getting either
50 or 51 heads,
being within plus or minus
one of the expectation?
It's about 1/7.
OK, let's flip more coins
and see what happens.
This time I'm going
to flip 1001 coins.
And again, the expected number
of heads is 500 and 1/2,
which I'll never get exactly.
The probability of getting
exactly 500 heads is 1/39,
and the probability of getting
within one of the expectation,
that is either 500 or
501 heads, is about 1/19.
Now, these numbers have gone
down from the previous numbers.
Remember, it was about 1/7
and we've gone down to 1/19.
So it's actually we're
less likely to be
within a fixed distance, within
one of the expectation when
we flip more coins.
So as the number of tosses
grows, the number of heads
gets less likely to be
within any given fixed
distance of the mean.
But things get better when we
start looking at percentages.
So what's the
probability of being
within 1% of the mean
if I toss 1,001 coins?
Well, 1% of 1,001 is about
10, so we're talking about 1%
of the 1,001.
And the probability of
being within 10 of 500.5,
that is to say the probability
of being within 510 and 490,
is about 0.49.
It's almost 50-50, which
is not really so bad.
So we have a 50/50
chance of actually
being within 1% of the expected
number when I flip 1,001 coins.
So what we can start
to say is that when
we're trying to give
the meaning to the mean,
if I let u be the standard
abbreviation for expectation
of R-- I'm doing that just
so it'll fit on the slide
nicely in formulas, so mu
is the expectation of R--
the basic question we're
asking is two basic questions.
One is, what's the probability
that the random variable is far
from its mean, mu?
You could phrase that as,
what's the probability
that the distance from R to
mu, the absolute value of R
minus mu is greater
than some amount, x.
And the second question
that we want to ask
is, what's the
average deviation?
What's the expectation of the
distance between R minus mu?
What's the expected
value of r minus mu?
Now, of course,
we're trying to make
sense of the meaning
of the expectation,
in terms of the expectation
of the distance between R
and this expectation.
So there's a little bit
of circularity there,
but let's live with
it and proceed.
Let's look at example to
crystallize the ideas a little.
Let's look at two dice
with the same mean.
The green die is going to be
a standard fair die, in which
each of the numbers
one through six
has an equal probability
of showing up,
and its expected
value is exactly
going to be the midpoint between
one and six, or 3 and 1/2.
Now, suppose I look
at a loaded die,
die two, which only
throws a one or a six,
but with equal probability.
Then, it's expectation is also 3
and 1/2, by the same reasoning.
So here are these
two different die.
One takes the values one
through six equally likely,
and the other takes only
the two values one and six,
but they have the
same expectation.
So how do I capture
the difference?
Well, if I look at the expected
distance of the fair die
to its mean, I claim
it's one and a half.
But the expected distance
of the loaded die
from its mean-- same mean
remember, 3 and 1/2--
is actually 2 and 1/2.
In fact, the second die is
always exactly 2 and 1/2
from its expected value.
Let's look at the PDFs to
get a grip on understanding
what's going on.
So here's the PDF
for the fair die.
Over one through six
the probability is 1/6,
so each of those green
spikes, columns, is 1/6 high.
And their total
is the probability
that the fair die takes one of
those values one through six
with equal likelihood.
Now, the expected
value is exactly
in the middle at 3 and 1/2.
And the average distance
of these points--
well, you can see that a
third of the time, you're
at distance 1/2, a
third of the time, that
is when you take
the values 2 and 5,
you are a distance
exactly 1 and 1/2.
And another third of the time,
you're at distance 2 and 1/2
when you take one and six.
And that averages out to the
middle value of 1 and 1/2.
So the expected deviation,
the expected distance,
of the fair die from
its mean is 1 and 1/2.
On the other hand, for the
loaded die, as we said,
it's always exactly 2
and 1/2 from its expected
value, which means its expected
value is also 2 and 1/2.
So we can start to see the
difference between these two
distributions and
these two kinds of die.
Even though they have the
same expectation, one of them
is more likely and has a
greater expected distance
from its mean.
And the moral of
this short piece
is that the mean alone
is not a good predictor
of a random variable's
behavior, as you might suppose.
One parameter, one
number is not going
to capture the shape of
a PDF, which gives you
more full information about
the distribution of values
of a random variable.
And we need some
more information
than just the expectation.
An especially, valuable
extra piece of information
that's still well less
than the overall shape
of the PDF of the
random variable,
is knowing its probable
deviation from its mean.